hi Brian I'm answering your question I
gotta motivate us an idea what's been
running through my mind a lot this
morning to suppose this new speakers who
are really really motivating is there's
a little yeah it's wonderful
it's almost if you're feeling afraid
that's a critter wonderful sign of Ben
all right place to do something about it
and a lot of that be coming out of a
conversation with the listening to is
mine and also to keep going of does
given Eric we've been talking people in
the face massive operation recession and
especially just get of mourning for one
going and then when you look back you'll
see how much you achieved but fear is
wonderful is kind of thing today